jacob degrom has gotten 32 runs of
support the last two games might not be
able to count on that large yes again
i think you look at the numbers only
four home runs allowed as he's averaging
six
innings per start bottom of the second
gene segura andrew knapp
and scott kingery will be the hitters
for the phillies
one ball and one strike to segura and a
light drive base it to right center
field
benfordo will get to it segora trying to
get to second and he
does i think he got to take that chance
i mean it pays off but i think he got to
do it
absolutely like you said you're not
going to string many hits together
against the grommet anytime you can grab
an extra base you got to do everything
you can to do it knapp did homer against
the ground
that one's hit sharply over the glove of
dom smith and down the right field line
rounding third is segura on his way to
second his nap
and he is safe at second and he's going
to keep on going a third
evan has just missed the throw
one-nothing
phillies i mean that ball was hit so
hard don
smith tried to get down on that one knee
scott was one for three last night with
a double homeward in his first game back
ball four that puts two on paisley
coming up
fly ball left field mcneil does not have
the throwing arm to talk about
tagging from third is knapp the throw
goes to the cut-off man frazier
two-nothing focus i think that tells you
they're trying to attack him early
and degrom's command is not as good as
it normally is
the phillies are doing what they have to
do to push runs across the board now
looper down the right field line that'll
be in for a base hit kingry on his way
to third
it was a first and third and still one
man down
jeremy hefner going out when's the last
time he's got a visit from the pitching
coach
in the second inning i don't know can't
imagine it's often
now another first to third situation
with only one out in the top of the
order
he goes pitch will be dug out by ramos
no throw
stolen base number nine for roman
without being caught
ground ball to shortstop jimenez is
coming home and
it's dropped by wilson ramos
three-nothing
phillies dennis comes in you see him try
to circle it throws off balance
kind of bounce it but i think that would
have been the same thing as that
game-winning play with
roman quinn so fielder's choice
rbi three-nothing phillies harper's got
to get this running he's
pulling off big time harper goes down
swinging
and that's the second out ball was in
the dirt throw to first and
out he picked him off mccutchen picked
off
ball in the dirt on strike three you
can't advance you can't
go to first base with less than two out
but mccutcheon for some reason
wandered off the bag so it's a strike
him out pick them off to end the inning
three runs for the phillies they lead
three nothing
and then in the likes of which jacob
degrom has not seen in a long time
three earned runs against his ledger in
the bottom of the second
the water bottle takes the brunt of it
the word on jacob degrom
is that he left the game with a right
hamstring
spasm bottom of the third and michael
walka
is the new pitcher for the mets
that one's in deep to left field going
back on it is mcneal and it
is gone a home run for segora
just over the small fence his sixth home
run of the year
and the phillies leading four-nothing
tonight
gene zigurus having right now big double
the lead off
the second inning that led to the three
runs for the phillies and now a two-out
solo so one out davis a third and robbie
cannell will try and get him in
hit on the ground nice stop by segura
throwing from a knee and he got him as a
run comes home
two fine infield plays behind wheeler
first
kangary and now segura davis comes in to
score the first med run of the night
to make it 4-1 philly nemo at second
with one out jd's three for seven in
this series
it's lifted out to right haisley goes
back takes a look and it's out of here
an opposite field two-run homer for j.d
davis to get the mets right back into
this game
number six for davis and it's now 4-3
philadelphia
well jd already has the biggest hits in
this game for the mets now he's got the
tying one at first with two out of the
eighth
and davis flies one out to right center
back goes hazel to the track back at the
wall
leaping he can't get it conforto to
third
he's being waved around the relay thrown
to the plate conforto sliding he's safe
and the game is tied jd davis with his
third extra base hit of the night
chases home conforto with the tying run
and the mets have come from
four runs down to get even so it's left
to jimenez you got rosario at second
mcneil at first
line center field base head here comes
rosario around
third quinn makes the throw to the plate
offline
and the mets have the lead andres
jimenez comes through with the go ahead
hit in the top of the ninth
and it's five to four new york
swing and a miss balls in the dirt throw
to second base they've got jimenez
mcneil's heading home kingry runs at him
and kimbry will race him down and tag
him in the backside
so the side is retired and they've got
the tying run aboard with dd gregorius
coming up
02. he struck him out and the ball game
is over
diaz strikes out three in the ninth the
mids come from four runs down
jd davis with a huge game andres jimenez
the go ahead hit on the ninth
and the mets get themselves a crucial
game and they defeat the phillies
5-4